all right so I got this kind of crazy
idea and that is that I can make a video
journal every day kind of and at the end
of the month I can edit it together and
you can kind of see how my month went
because you just only see reviews and
things and videos it doesn't really I
don't know [ __ ] he's behind the scenes
so as I pet dangers head and so I was
like hey that could be fun let's do that
so the end I'm wearing this robe it's so
damn comfortable I could wear it forever
and it's January 1st right now 2019 so
this is how the month of January went
for me first video of the new year which
is my top 10 anticipated movies 2019
which I based the top 10 so who's really
gonna be satisfied by this people are
gonna be so pissed at how to train your
dragon 3 he's not on here I'm also
really tired too so if I look tired in
my top 10 anticipated movies 2019 videos
because I really am tired those secrets
that's why I have a migraine today
that's cool
get him all the time so that's the whole
thing to know about me but woke up to
see people talking about my anticipated
movies 2019 video cuz it uploaded that
last night people seem to like it if I
called it the the best Stephen King
horror adaptation people are like what
about The Shining so yeah I forgot about
that one so that's cool
but I'm on the trending tab and that's
cool which means more people are gonna
see me say that over the shining so
that's cool but I stand by what I said
good ships just look in my hands thank
you Jim I'll be honest with you I don't
think it's possible for me to go about
the day the custom coffee there's
Christmas present
today's agenda is I'm going to my mom's
house to help remove furniture it's a
part of adulthood no one told me that
but it I guess it is and it's January
4th and I still have my Christmas tree
up it'll come down around February for
the record I hate moving pianos so the
pianos have been moved the work is done
so now I'm at Best Buy shopping for
cameras because I was invited to go play
Mortal Kombat 11 this month it's cool so
I have to go fly down to LA but I'd like
another camera other than my DSLR so my
best my shopping for cameras camera so
many options I don't film in 4k I don't
need it plus I'm cheap so while we're
here we might as well shop let's shop
for stuff I don't like you you don't
like me you didn't make this movie now I
feel like they could never make a movie
like this now it's kind of the beauty of
it turn these things around and
underneath the little caps are dog
traits and I don't know that they
understand that rest assured the one
that's done is because we showed him boo
dangerous pigging out
gypsies missing all the trees now
gypsies decided to guard it and growl it
danger it's like my brother and I when
we fight over the Super Nintendo
Oh [ __ ] don't be a dick I'm making a
video baby cuz this is what happens when
girlfriend says hey I'm gonna organize
your kitchen head yes for the record I
have old people Tupperware it's not
Tupperware it's Corning Works Courtney
where is awesome update for the record
for the record it wasn't this messy it's
not like it was this messy and she was
like hey I'm gonna clean it and organize
it it was clean it was clean ish and she
was like it wasn't organized it's just
like let's organize the [ __ ] out of it
so it you have to the night is darkest
just before the dawn you have to destroy
it
and rip everything out of the cupboards
you're not gonna clean it you didn't so
guys I think it's fine the way it is now
time to organize the Wreckers generally
it's soundtrack
rock-and-roll and classical or
thereabouts
we were watching TV and then the power
just went out in gifs poor tips he's
just scared out of her mind
oh yeah seeing her her own reflection a
little so after a lot of BestBuy
research I bought a camera on Amazon the
Panasonic Lumix G H by L this is not
sponsored by it I like the DSLR look and
I like the fact that I guess you can
continually film with this it won't shut
off after 10 minutes or so which I
really like all yours oh we got to test
out the camera in the only way I know
how
[Music]
obviously I have a long way to go before
I get used to this new camera it's the
fun of new tech so now I'm thinking it
was a little indulgent a little
overboard to get that camera probably my
Canon 60d does just fine for what I do
so I might return it get something a
little simpler since I only need this
camera to play a video game
one time so if I move around more
frequently and go to conventions and
film there more frequently I'll get
something a little cooler like this so I
might return it really cool camera
though as I sit here with my bed head
I've learned that there is another
Captain Marvel trailer a sneak peek
minute and a half long trailer it could
do a video on it or
I'm still hard to film and play a game
at the same time for some reason I just
suddenly wanted to watch an episode of
Smallville so I have they're so amazing
my god I got a vacuum look at these
Tufts of fur see you all right so I'm
watching Smallville and playing Zelda
and listening to Castlevania music would
it hits me that and I had to go back and
watch the the Captain Marvel trailer the
new one but history that she has a
shield hat it's called shield but they
didn't create shield they didn't call it
shield until Iron Man 1 did did they I'm
now editing my video for my Captain
Marvel trailer 3 video talking about the
continuity of when they created shield
when they said they created the
continuity is important I'm just saying
it's important well it's January 9th
which means I should definitely have my
stockings and Christmas stuff taken down
but it's the next morning after the
great video I did on Captain Marvel and
when did they come up with the name
shield people were like yeah cause it
was so let's move on and we didn't get
that or he withheld information I feel
like Coulson trolled me 10 years ago I'm
just now figuring it out yeah that's not
good also January 9th reviews of glass
have come out which means it's gonna be
a week of people requesting I review
glass not knowing that I don't see it
until next week so here here's to the
next six days or so I mean I would then
how would you know you wouldn't know I
haven't told you don't know and now my
review for glass should be out so it is
what it is damnit living in the
northwest it's like we get reviews last
or something I hate Seattle traffic
gonna watch the upside it looks nice
hopefully it's good but still see I'm
traffic is complete ass [ __ ] you and
your blinker so here I am and there they
are
so we're watching the upside who's guys
sat next to me they're like your gym
it's sweet we'll sit next to you and
we'll watch the upside so Chris Joe and
Joe and they represent you it was an
interesting movie you have a friends or
a grandma and you're like we need to go
watch a movie like suggested confusing
it parts you know what from the bottom
of my heart thank you for not talking
during the movie okay huh because that's
important okay Chris and Joel do not
talk during the movie it's like so
Amazon round 2 press so I returned the
last camera it's a bit overkill I see
something to film once so once again
Amazon trusty cardboard cutters this
thing should do just fine for what I
need plus it's all like sleek looking I
like this perfect I heard a statistic I
felt like 70% of youtubers useless thing
which who are kidding though that
statistic doesn't really mean jack [ __ ]
because we're concerned with what the 1%
deal is and I got a light which is funny
because now that I'm thinking about it
this light might be a bit too big for
this thing it won't even work how am I
supposed to put a light on this thing
wow that's bright sorry but your eyes
are you doing this is gypsy she's very
shy I'm here editing this is where I
edit and editing is just the longest
part of a youtubers life I realize that
I'm pretty sure the lorule Castle Fame
in Legend of Zelda a link between worlds
pretty sure that song would go with the
step in time footage from Mary Poppins
I'm gonna try to edit that and we'll see
what happens what about Instagram if it
works I'm laying in my bed and a barrage
of pillows and blankets I gotta watch
that Keanu Reeves movie about clone
or whatever the [ __ ] I don't want her
this is what it's work this is when
YouTube's work that Keanu Reeves movie
replicas just got back from it oh my god
I know I gotta do a review on it I told
my gonna close though this is what I
wore for the last review come on
I'll wear the shirt all day for the
second day in a row and I'm gonna wear
it in a video don't you guys know I do
that a video that's not this video
because now you already know I'm not an
animal
my smoke alarm beeped and gypsy hates it
when that happens so she's scared now
she was just outside that's why she's
wet she didn't get slimed by slime or
anything
gypsy we vacuumed it's soap
I should have mentioned danger only
cares about fetch and yes I am wearing
pajama bottoms Harry Potter pajamas
Slytherin baby hey so we're at IKEA the
greatest oh look at this no no it's
great it's great
and this is our forgiving light we have
to do this otherwise we look like
shadowy Lich's for life so we're gonna
shop for things I don't even know what
things what we're gonna shop for thing
girlfriends a bliss let's jump on the
bed but going against the arrows like
rebels they're gonna go to jail for this
while shopping at IKEA
who ran into Jonathan Jonathan is the
man Jonathan has great taste he helped
what he helped us find bookshelves
Jonathan's the man that's the people at
home people at home Jonathan no man
dangerous danger losing his [ __ ] because
there's so many toys around here for him
to play with but he wants that in
defense of me I was told they'd grew up
to be dogs and they're just puppies
forever gypsy had like a weird eye
booger hair it's freaking me out there
we go yeah he's like dehydrated it's
tough work being a spoiled [ __ ] also
tough work being one of the cutest dogs
ever Oh buddy oh [ __ ] and hold onto it
establish your doughnuts all right now
he's gonna lose his mind again I think
Cesar Millan abhi like [ __ ] with them
out Jeremy's life he must be high
rolling he must like live in a footnote
this was my life my dogs rule my life
they're really cute though it's
Operation onslaught
what toy wins which one wins that's the
one the one they've been fighting over
the floor fire Alexa play calming music
for dogs [ __ ] yeah I guess this is
magical WC who knew it's already working
they're so calm she's hypnotized
dangerous emerging allergy day so who's
sexy welcome to reality yeah we're
videoing now hi Internet this is the
important thing in life to remember
so knowing the madness remember two
things date night which is tonight and
queen without a copyright claim or five
morning after date night meat like
leftover date night meat is the best
breakfast ever
it's not a metaphor for [ __ ] I hear you
laughing over there a nice rare bloody
rare steak the next morning is there a
better breakfast and this is how much I
love you Vanessa is a vegan so I ordered
the grass-fed filet out of respective we
are upping our old person routine game
significantly is a thousand-piece puzzle
in best dangers ball it's a lot more
than we thought just want to swim
through it like Scrooge McDuck some
money bin but it's puzzles it's like a
puzzle thing look how interested they
are already connected
that's cheating it's got a new table
today it's really nice and we figured
we'd really show how 30s we are not
1930s but aged 30s by doing a
thousand-piece puzzle on it please don't
think I'm cool because now you have
proof that I'm not this is how we
weekend and if you don't weekend like
this yet you [ __ ] will we have
committed we've made coffee we're
committing to doing this thousand-piece
puzzle tonight you ready sure but we
need to for king and country as I stand
in front of the Warriors of Eternia fact
is we just couldn't finish the jigsaw
puzzle thousand pieces
we're tired so going to bed but we'll
finish it and you'll see it happen so
I'm on a huge fire emblem kick right now
I'm making coffee
oh all right so it's Monday that the
hell is today January Monday of the
middle of the month
Universal sent me a box of something I
was just funny I'm pretty sure it's
Halloween [ __ ] not as in the season but
is in the movie it's actually thinking
alright that's pretty cool I have a
Michael Myers mask there's a face sore
either a gunshot wound
knife wound or a very bad blistering
open sore which I've been telling Mikey
for years lay off the meth cover up my
bed head for Michael Myers hair gar
Mondays what else the blu-ray I mean
it's not the 4k but it'll do I guess my
rating is blu-ray so my eye itches hold
on look like my face is melting like
[Music]
Decco that's pretty neat this is this
very good Halloween mask as in the
season not the movie so I'll be fun to
put my window or scare kids or something
like that so that's pretty cool funny
enough I don't want to talk about this
because I've wanted to talk about it in
a video for the longest time but I'm
usually doing reviews I just feel like
it's not the format this is a perfect
format in terms of studio 7 people
Michael Myers heads and and robes from
El Royale and what is that [ __ ] and it's
something called rule of reciprocation
great I just probably also tweeted out
so people buy the blu-ray know about it
and have fun with it on your social
media sure but more than that rule of
reciprocation what that is is that's the
concept of when people give you
something you're more inclined to give
them something in return it's like when
you're walking in the mall and someone's
like hey you want a sample of teriyaki
chicken you're like sure and you eat
that sample of teriyaki chicken you're
more likely to eat their food now then
go somewhere else that's called the rule
of reciprocation because you're gonna
reciprocate the favor so I always think
about that I definitely do think that
studios are playing up rule of
reciprocation like absolutely they are
it's like they want me to look at this
and go oh that was really cool so if
there's a Halloween - I'm more likely to
go you know that was fun because the
studio was nice to me that one time with
this crushed head again the universal
thanks I like the mask and I will use it
to scare the [ __ ] out of some kids but I
know it's rule of reciprocation so it's
not going to make a difference if you
make a sequel and it sucks just you got
to know that I just want you to people
and youtubers to know that they're kind
of their pawns in the whole game of
online chatter for entertainment if
Studios give you free [ __ ] they're
hoping for a rule of reciprocation
they're hoping that at least at the
subconscious level you will remember
this and you will be more likely to be
nice to them if they make something that
sucks this is not the fault of youtubers
or critics or anything it's really just
it's why Studios do its the game but
remember that phrase rule of
reciprocation all right so that's my
rant I'm done I also really enjoyed
getting a couple free things before I
never get any more I can just change
that we should suffer so much fear in
doubt it was so small the thing I'm
updating my framemeister this is the
micro SD card here's hoping framemeister
for those of you who don't know is this
little thing right here and it allows
you to play classic consoles on modern
TVs without any of the pixelization and
[ __ ] well it's gonna be a busy day
today so today I mean I just planned on
having to drop my daughter off at my
mom's and then go to Seattle screen
glass record the review for glass upload
it and then tomorrow fly out from Mortal
Kombat but the spider-man far from home
trailer just dropped so what I have to
do there's the order of operations film
the spider-man far from home video
upload that video take my my dogs to my
mom's go to Seattle watch glass comeback
record my review for glass upload that
video and then tomorrow fly out so if
I'm exhausted during my Mortal Kombat
gameplay that's why oh my goodness flat
like that what are you doing alright so
I finished my spider-man far from home
trailer video but not fast enough to do
it and have time to drop the dogs off at
my mom's place so after I see class what
I'm gonna do alright now taking the dogs
over to my mom's you pump to hang out at
Mom's for a couple days all right well
fine like [ __ ] you do I don't know why I
am so tired I still need to film edit
and upload my review for glass it's 11
18 p.m. and I just want a baby but I'm
making coffee we will get that review
for glass to you or my dishes dirty okay
it's not too bad you can't see I was
gonna call it wreckage but you can't see
[ __ ] it's 409 in the morning and I'm
finally exporting my review for glass
it's funny because I watch it it's the
big part of it's pretty much me like I
like I'm breakable and doesn't do
unbreakable justice which is very
one-sided and subjective as [ __ ] but
that's just me how I am Helen yeah
critic go into the airport I'm at the
airport at the
boy gonna play mismo to combat that's a
hop in the TSA check wonder if I can
leave this on as it goes through the
x-ray machine I would but I told one who
think I'm sort of like they like spy
spies who got through the TSA check no
one put the thumb up my ass a little
disappointed about that I thought was
normal procedure maybe was just Earl
that one time in Chicago holiness is
gonna be so jealous I'm hungry like I
know airport food it's the exact look
people think when they think good food
but in terms of airport food this place
is actually it's pretty good it's
actually good in terms of food you dig
this hotel it's called the lime and
actually it's nice it's really its
proper douchey I like it although let me
try to flip this thing around it's like
all the walls are made out of stone and
[ __ ] stone bombs because paint is so
20th century so for some miraculous
reason my laptop won't connect to the
Wi-Fi here don't know why my phone does
who went down to the helpdesk so like
all of our laptops do all the Mortal
Kombat videos over the Mortal Kombat
video I'm gonna get might not upload
until I get back on Friday
oh I don't even give a [ __ ] I'm
recording now like are you so I already
I already laughed down the hallways the
hallways of the rooms are the same were
it does look like I'm at the airport
in a box that's in the parking garage
for sure so Ellie oh there's nothing
more LA than this place yeah there's
birds made out of junk and metal on the
walls I mean it's pretty [ __ ] cool
I'm just saying these bottles are shaped
like shampoo ketchup and Pennzoil and
they don't do anything they are made out
of stone and I hate the feel of them
entirely yeah yeah we're crabby as
[ __ ] I go downstairs gonna place
okay I guess there's a juggling chapter
attempt to three trailer that just
dropped grab little combat it's a full
day ran into boogie any of us is like
we're all just like buyers [ __ ] up but
we're in the line and speaking of [ __ ]
up
we all got bracelets so we can drink so
we're going to the airport
no one searched my ass but I think here
they did my god Security's crazy for
coming it's more madness I started doing
this vlog thing I want to do it to show
you how boring my life is this this is
the antithesis of that it's usually not
this exciting
so the events winding down angry Joe and
I threw down I'm sure the audios
complete ass I'm sorry about that
there's a retro game store next to this
dude's Co he thought I drank this jokey
got really [ __ ] tongue out
all right so me well angry Joe and
myself we split from the Mortal Kombat
event but now we're on the track to go
to a used game store because retro games
man
why not first of all that used data
story so is yeah that place is kind of a
[ __ ] alright so we won't be chopping
it we're going back now or uber into a
proper one so because the convention has
the audio of our our voices in shitty
audio quality mixed in with the audio
file of the video file that is gameplay
we're trying to hammer it through it's
looking very bleak the audio for this
gameplay footage of Joe and I fighting
in Mortal Kombat 11 might just be ass
like worse than we thought alright now
this retro game store is legit this is
cool yeah this is the other one
literally smelt like bird catfish all
right so the Mortal Kombat 11 angry Joe
versus me video a lot of fun to do
pretty finished in terms of editing I'll
have it up tomorrow and there is no way
around it the audio just sucks dick
cheese I hate that I contemplated not
putting it up but I want to put it up
because it was fun so if you got through
it with the bad audio bless you so I
have to be in the lobby at 7:15 slept
through my alarm naturally woke up at
7:00
like we had packed last night yeah like
you're on that one so I've landed I'm
back home I get this email reminding me
because I posted an Instagram picture of
me holding a skull and drink at the
blood the Mortal Kombat thing and it was
like remember you have to hashtag
sponsored by Warner Brothers which it is
everything flew me out for sure
puppy I'm in the hotel the whole works
you know rule of reciprocation so we
forgot to say hey you by the way what do
brothers flew us out so it's all become
so corporate and [ __ ] that said yeah
they flew us out it was fun brought to
you by WB games so it's rendering one
frame a second this Mortal Kombat video
with shitty audio one frame a second
40,000 frames which is 666 minutes which
is about eleven point something hours
thus sayeth Alexa the Amazon echo 11
hours Alexa no one gives a [ __ ] you
realize done the robots take over she's
gonna remember I said that Alexa you're
beautiful yeah yeah yeah she's over she
overcooked it a little bit your mega
Vanessa jealous of the fact that I still
have my Christmas at that point is this
is gonna take forever
all right set my alarm for 7:00 a.m.
still has an hour of exporting to go so
I guess I sit here for an hour but got
some fire cool while making gains on
Fire Emblem now the Mortal Kombat
footage is uploading and it looks like
it's gonna go live right at 9:00 so
among all the technical fuck-ups of the
upload technical fuck-ups of the
recording the shitty sound the the
grainy picture because the light I
brought actually burned out because it
was on
[Music]
it was a lot of fun so here's to the
most strained uploaded video for who
knows what as long as it's fun and don't
wear headphones while watching it I'm
telling people if you're wonderful
wallpaper work so got new wallpaper and
it looks nice but more importantly it's
the weekend which means one thing it's
puzzle time unmoved untouched since last
weekend been here for a week it is time
to conclude the chapter
[Music]
with my fat head and hand I'm driving in
the rain checking of my dad to go to my
mom's to hang a chandelier without her
knowing
so she gets home from work and she's
like okay my new chandelier is hung up
that's really cool so a few of these
days my mom I was top of only this time
she doesn't know so it's kind of gold
there to go to Fred Meyer to get a screw
for a bolt or something point is I'm
hungry as hell
so girls would crap your deli food okay
so hanging chandeliers
so I'm eBay I just bid on contra 3 the
alien wars I'm going to bed which means
a sniper might take out my bed but we'll
see
I'll leave the widow with a smile or
wake up going to well [ __ ] well [ __ ] I
woke up on the bed count to three
[Music]
off to murder pod that shows cancelled
off to murder podcast for small-town
murder question mark I think that's what
it does small-town murder
that's this huge fan of it and so I
listen to it when I'm in the car with
her and we were like hey they have a
they have a thing like a live show that
they're doing in Seattle so we're going
to it we Came we saw I'm blurry as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] we can't we saw we learned
about murder get healthy they all that
[ __ ] around him like all those toys and
socks
alright so what's kind of cool is I got
Resident Evil 2 is still the case which
I guess I didn't get a lot of but i
pre-ordered it pretty sure I was
inebriated sometimes I forgot that I
ordered it
I'm glad i pre-ordered it because I got
still ok so what do you something yours
they make you play this [ __ ] or isn't an
evil bag of the day so I'm pretty
excited so it's the end of the month
so it's about time for me to edit this
thing together but as one last blast of
fun I'm meeting my friend Nathan at a
sushi place but I love sushi friends
like a twofer editing Resident Evil
review watching house I mean if this
isn't living I don't know what is my
Resident Evil T review went live 6 a.m.
and in the review I said I played as
Claire in passe I also said hey the
tyrant never crashes through the wall
I've been informed now he does when he
plays Leon impasse so they say so the
legend tells us so that's the
conversation in the comment section but
most of the conversation in the comments
section dead zombie sketch is pretty
cool there right oh man so did I get
like more comments because of it
or people just like they would have
commented something else I don't know so
that's it it's pretty much my January or
the things half worth showing the other
half that things really worth showing I
was probably invested in as they were
happening so couldn't joke because if
you're taking time recording something
you're not taking time enjoying
something so it's just a law of life one
thing I learned
definitely through this is that I hate
my bottom teeth
with a passion I hate looking at them I
hate seeing them when I edit
I'm just really phobic of dentists and
orthodontists is from childhood I don't
like them so I never got my wisdom teeth
out different conversation for another
time but I think 2019 might be the year
I get that [ __ ] fixed so we'll say if
you guys like this this little journal
idea thing and you'll soon as is
happening so there is that but let me
know let me know this is a cool idea let
me know if you should be shorter maybe
every other week thing so hey here's the
first two weeks of the month here's the
next two weeks of the month sorry again
sorry I got it to you late just been
busy I wanted to get this to you like on
the first of the month you're getting it
a few days to weekend is what it is but
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]